jacques est maintenant
bonsoir oui après à peu près leur
faisait 32 ans d'être marseillais auteur
compositeur producteur leader du groupe
iam et aussi d'autres disques en solo
sous votre nom propre
alors on sortait un deuxième album qui
va deuxième album solo chez hostile
c'est comment on fait comment j'ai un
problème au bras l'a alors moins de
poids allez-y je me sens c'est comment
on fait des petites mains comme ça
l arrêt
c'est pourquoi j'ai peur et je suis ton
émission est partie du comité avec
baffie et ramifié des réseaux dormants
très organisé j'ai le disque
et alors six ans je vais [ __ ] et mat
vous sortez un album qui s'appelle sol
invictus le premier single ses
impressions et voilà
extrait de ce mx us agression par
akhenaton alors s'élever à 5 min tit
célia soleil invincible pourquoi ce
symbole symbole pas liens non c'est un
symbole c'est un palace ses mollets
romain mais en fait c'est plus pour dire
en fait un symbole payet qui retournait
pour pour être un symbole en fait de
croyance le soleil est invincible
le soleil est une création de dieu du
est invincible ouais vous savez quand
même qu'il y avait des ss qui défilait
sous ce symbole il y avait des ss qui
n'est fini sous symbole puisque ça
c'était c'est un peu le côté obscur qui
dans l'album que je décris dans ce
morceau de sa position puisqu'ils un
côté de sol invictus que j'ai des fans
côté que je condamne et dans des paroles
du morceau qui s'appelle j'aime jeudi
mais à travers des pages je compris que
n'est pas trois sont les noirs et ait
lui même temps nous doit la croix il
faut vous le savez que moi ces voix là
alors il ya une vraie dichotomie entre
le titre de l'album le soleil est
invincible et puis le ton un petit peu
nostalgique presque désabusé des paroles
non oui de la nostalgie de l'amertume ne
s'agit vis-à-vis de l'adolescence
amertume vis-à-vis de de relations
amicales ou de vision du que
que j'ai sur l'europe maintenant alors
quand vous étiez jeune vous habitiez à
marseille à plan de cuques à la sortie
de marseille votre mère qui nous a
élevés avec votre frère fabien est
devenu votre manager aujourd'hui et à
l'époque vous appelait encore philippe
fragione parce que vous êtes petit fils
d'immigré napolitain cabré est une
chanson album y verront un pas qui parle
de ce à quoi le pays
alors votre maire employés edf divorce
et militante syndicaliste cgt et vous
mais j'étais magnifique les haut
parleurs
je pense qu'elle tenait par haut parleur
mais l'a été pas mal sac et d'inde ans
dans l'entreprise
enfin edf parce qu'elle a été militante
je pense qu'elle a perdu ses illusions
je suis désolé avec le socialisme peut
qui a quitté une sorte de deux pintes et
maquillés de la gauche les socialistes
s'ils finissent toujours par sauver la
bourgeoisie finalement exactement si
j'ai eu plein de choses à dire à combien
elle est là non non mais je ça fait
partie des débats publics non mais je
comprends il ya des deux sur l'histoire
de la gauche c'est pas que des c'est pas
que des triomphes 1 c'est aussi des
échecs et même sans doute des
souffrances pour des militants je le
comprends très bien votre mère à y
croyez quand elle a vu arriver mi temps
elle a sauté à sauter à la santé de sa
chaise à chazé tomber tout le monde chez
moi sauter je suis d'une famille au
rouge mois de 1 2 est donc ils ont sauté
et je retombe depuis qu'ils sont passés
en dessous de la table alors à l'école
me dit que j'étais un insoumis c'est un
terme très fort et sincère pour l'emploi
poe d'habitude pour l'armée se soit
donné aux antilles vous étiez pas à
turbulent non pas du tout je pense que
j'étais plutôt insoumis dans ce qu'on
nous obliger à faire qui me semble
injuste du jardin quand on a mis le
samedi après midi le mercredi après midi
avec des interros obligatoirement cher
aucune parce que j'ai jugé que mercredi
après midi c'était pour leur opposer
bien lors des deux chocs culturels dans
votre enfance d'abord quand votre mère
vous achète une encyclopédie pour
enfants vendus en porte à porte qui
s'appelle tout l'univers en 24 volumes
là c'est le choc
vous découvrez ou redécouvrez les
dinosaures d'abord elle même découvrir
l'égypte ancienne c'est seydou aké
natondé toutes les civilisations
antiques d'ailleurs jeu c'est ainsi
qu'au petit il était drôlement bien fait
puisque pour les enfants y avait
beaucoup dit d'image et je suis passé du
fait de peu de la période de la
séparation de mes parents je les lui du
premier volume et donc vous flashez sur
akhenaton serviteur du disque solaire
qui est qui était en fait un pharaon
l'époux de néfertiti je peux apprendre
pardon tu m'as avoir un truc si bien que
n'at-on saddam et akhenaton c'est
passionnant c'est le premier qui a
introduit le culte monothéiste en egypte
et mon truc intelligent tout le monde
vu à succès glee tout en seulement
séparent le car qui lui alors parce que
le pays s'était évité avec akhenaton on
peut dire la vérité
énorme toutankhamon vous pouvez sortir
il a toujours joué en bas rhin d'autant
qu'avant on est enfin sous l'impulsion
du clergé de tableau et du clergé de
thèbes
absolument et la sanction service unique
ça tu vois michel là on apprend des
trucs en même temps sur le deux risquent
de basculer alors premier choc culturel
donc on l'a dit c'est tout l'univers
deuxième choc culturel quelques années
plus tard vous découvrez le rap en
écoutant une émission qui s'appelle
starting blocs sur radio star et 13 ans
180 justement et la radio est installé
sur les hauteurs de marseille dans une
bergerie flotteurs de marseille et vous
l'avez racheter aujourd'hui vous allez
installer votre studio de dans quoi on
va gérer la boucle est bouclée sa boucle
est bouclée on est en a un à nos bureaux
nos studios d'un soldat qu'il était
magique parce que c'est qu'armand et les
émissions qui monte qui m'ont mis dans
cette musique qui était mise de ce viol
à ce lieu mythique puis carrément
inconnus qui a annoncé dès le début des
restaurants du coeur il ya madonna qui
est venu donc c'est un lieu chargé
d'histoire même si c'est une bergerie 1
alors en france à marseille
en france assez chaude dans un quartier
assez chaud un jour il ya un mec qui dit
à un de vos copains se ressemblent à
fernandel c'est vrai ça le mec il est
monté il a pris un phil schiller
descendu de la tuer ouais nan mais merci
morcenx et à l'air de s'améliorer
allez marseille de mes 12 ans et s était
plus les agités comme maintenant non non
ça s'est calmé un peu mais bon on peut y
aller en prison
bon alors là vous partez à new york un
vous partez à brooklyn dans la famille
de votre père vous resté deux ans et
demi là bas et là c'est la découverte
effectivement du hip hop du rap est
assez folkloriques et des horaires et là
bas vous avez été en contact avec tout
ce que le hip hop compte de l'époque -
et surtout les artistes des années d'or
du hip hop à 6,87 points et 8 mois avant
venait un jour un peu chez votre père
cette fois qui responsables
informatiques la sécurité sociale et au
moment de passer le bac et même etc dot
là qui vous qui vous résume assez bien
qu'elle attend au mandat c'est le belge
est agacé d'attendre devant la porte de
l'examinateur et vous vous sauver ses
joues au foot et quand vous racontez ça
je perds et beedie du monde devant la
porte du monde devant la porte et on
trouvera toute ta vie et vous dites-vous
suite à ça cette réflexion m'a appris à
pas vouloir passer devant les autres
mais a cassé la porte
je pense que quelqu'un parce que quand
on a fait du rap
quand on a fait cette musique là on a
l'habitude de voir les portes se
refermer de 25 et puis les portants
c'est un cliché mais on a près les
ouvrages tout seul et à plusieurs qu'on
a dû casser et même toujours maintenant
plus qu'un artiste de rap est toujours
doit lutter sans cesse contre ces
clichés
1 mais chaque fois j'ai l'impression que
chaque fois qu'on ressort que quoi que
ce soit il faut toujours expliquer mais
c'est vrai capitalise pas cantonné quand
on est un artiste de hip hop on
capitalise pas sur une carrière vous
passer le bac d un candidat libre docks
de biologie et puis après voulait être
archéologue évidemment à cause de
l'egypte est indiana jones mais vous
dites je me suis arrêté à ça c'est drôle
à la fac vous dites je me suis arrêté à
la table des joueurs de cartes à la
cafétéria y avait des magnifiques baby
foot et il est très belle table avec des
très bons joueurs de belote contrée donc
mam à ma carrière scolaire s'est arrêtée
supernationals enlève le père vous dit
avec monsieur faire du rap tu te
démerdes et laird en sol invictus est
une chanson qui s'appelle le fiston
c'est un petit peu l'histoire d'un père
qui a peur pour son fils êtes-vous
aujourd'hui ça va vous arriver parce que
votre fils yanis quand il va avoir 15
ans il faut pas bien non
ou alors continuer ses études
dans une fois nettement quand il est en
âge de décider ce qui ce qui va il fera
strictement ce qui lui plaît tant au
niveau de sa carrière je pense que s'il
part pas en vrille et comme on dit tout
va bien précis il a des ambitions
j'aime pause rien aux enfants même nom
mais sur un plan des croyances et tout
ça c'est un petit peu il faut dire la
vérité c'est un petit peu parti en
vrille après cette époque là c'est des
années zone les années un petit peu
galère vous y tellement abîmée de
l'intérieur j'ai perdu cinq ans de ma
vie à rester assis en insultant le monde
entier en croyant que c'était la faute
des autres
alors été comme hiver vous étiez au
métro vieux port comme résidence
tellement vous étiez à cet endroit là
qu'un jour ya la bonne femme de l'office
du tourisme
elle leur donne une boîte de chocolats
lui dans une boîte de chocolats et
succès [ __ ] vous a pris pour un
clochard et là ça vous a fait réfléchir
je crois que le réveillon du jour de
l'an voilà je dire il faut faire quelque
est quand même quelque chose rare elle
contenait pas de déchets
je me crois qu'on va faire quelque chose
et la voilà tout s'est mis en marche
musique maïs blanc
nos bébelles sécher une ouverture à
stockton à la une des femmes ça je veux
voir quand ils sont passés aux victoires
de la musique c'est trop fort serge il
se plaît à les doter leur culte dans
tout juste voulu édifiant
les quinze jours par mois voilà c'est
fait mais bon comme ça
france 20 ans
les bruits jamais revenu
on n'est plus jamais renoncer tandis que
la cgt bien en continu mais c'est moi ou
encore le château de l'état
été émaillée voilà ça c'est mes oreilles
d'âne la musique du film comme un
remaniement
tieger aujourd'hui j'ai commencé l'été
le moment aujourd'hui les a juste eu de
pression vient alors vous êtes converti
un lien ah oui c'est bien ça vous êtes
converti à l'islam en 92 peu avant votre
mariage avec aïcha pourquoi tout
simplement
donc est ce que savent plus l'islam par
rapport à cateau c'est une réforme
l'islam est la dernière des religions
c'est la suite logique de du judaïsme du
catholicisme et l'islam et à la et la
réforme puisque en fait le dernier des
prophètes qui s'appelle mohamed est venu
pour réformer la religion catholique est
vraiment pour nous la différence se
situe au simple fait que jésus n'est pas
mort sur la croix
1 voilà elle n'a pas été crucifié il a
été substitué explique non il a été
substitué n'est pas mort sur la croix et
des morands selon selon nous un soixante
et dix en egypte donc voila vous
plaignez beaucoup en france par exemple
vous dit un jour dans un train vous avez
gueuler contre le contrôleur
parce qu'avec eux des sandwiches au
jambon par exemple visite dans un pays
où il ya des juifs où il ya des
musulmans
c'est quand même un drame quelques
dessins de 13 des banques et de paris
depuis 12 heures et il prévoit des
sandwichs pour les passagers et jeudi
c'est quand même pratique que dans un
pays où il ya 10% 12% des gens qui ne
mangent pas de porc on peut voir que des
sandwichs jambon
c'est ce genre d'outil de petits trucs
qui relate bien l'esprit de fond qui est
que dans les pays anglo saxons certain
communautarisme est pas la solution
idéale et nous on n'a pas la bonne
solution non plus parce que c'est la
solution se trouve entre les deux
l'intervention par l'appellation le
contrat d'intégration encore moins pour
la simulation
parce que ce qu'on veut en france c'est
faire une assimilation c'est pas
l'intégration qu'on veut c'est pouvoir
si la république ça jean glavany là
c'est à dire que c'est vrai que c'est un
petit peu réducteur la république c'est
à dire que tout le monde doit s'est
parée du ctma si public c'est
l'intégration mange mais
les lois de la république à attention
les lois de la vie qu'elles ne sont pas
réductrice et une et oppressive elles
sont libératrices au contraire est
protectrice et moi je
autant je ponds je comprends la révolte
contre je compte du train contre
l'option mèche au jambon donc j'ai cru
comprendre qu'il y avait quand même un
peu près veut il ya un peu de révolte
ans je pense que c'est parce que notre
respect de notre époque n'est pas encore
assez laïque
oui exactement on va de la place à
toutes les religions voilà voilà
et oui mon raisonnement moi je considère
qu'une république qui ne permet pas à
12% des siens de pratiquer leur religion
au grand jour qui les oblige à le faire
dans des caves ou dans des hangars et
les cévennes je suis confuse des
mosquées y compris à paris après faut
pas s'étonner que ceux qui sont frustrés
se révoltent ou le fasse d'une manière
violente et la vraie laïcité c'est pas
d' empêcher de croire c'est de permettre
à tout le monde de croire en liberté et
en tolérance c'est pour cela que je dis
dans le même truc un miracle quand on a
quand les américains ont décidé
l'embargo il dort était bien plus fort
de donner à manger la population avec
des gros sacs avaient marqué usa dessus
et les gens seraient plus facilement
retourner contre le régime la halle
c'est raté là un sénateur au revoir je
vous salue voilà bientôt et bravo